drip drip drip if you see the telltale
black mucus dripping from the wall
behind you splattering down from the
ceiling then it is already too late for
you the plaster will start to split the
wood will warp and rot metal will rust
you should try to run attempt to hide
but know that he is coming for you
the old man
limping along relentlessly never
stopping to rest to eat to catch his
breath he has no need for such human
things anymore you can't fight him you
can't reason with him and you can't kill
what might as well already be dead just
when you think you've found a safe place
to hide you'll hear a creaking from the
floor below you a blinding pain as
something sharp slashes through your
achilles tendon is the last thing you
will feel before the decrepit nightmare
vision drags you to his lair never to
return even if you could escape now the
sickness is already in you skin already
slackening and muscles beginning to
liquefy he
is wrought he
is death he is the disintegration of all
hope and light and he has made you his
prey we've covered
scp-106 or the old man before we've
talked about his abilities his hunting
patterns an incident in which he escaped
and a variety of theories regarding his
origin it is unknown for sure where
exactly the old man came from there are
three major theories as to his true
origin which created one of the most
fearsome anomalies the scp foundation
has ever come across perhaps he was a
deeply disturbed world war one soldier
who gazed too long into something better
left untouched perhaps he was never
human at all but instead a divergent
humanoid species that preyed on early
prehistoric mankind today we're focusing
on the third possibility and arguably
the most tragic of the three it begins
with another man we've covered on the
channel before named dr robert scranton
and his wife dr anna lang you probably
know them for two things the scranton
reality anchor and the accidental
discovery of scp-3001
or the red reality in case you haven't
seen our video on the subject here's a
brief recap of the whole unfortunate
affair on january 2nd 2000 at site 120
robert and anna were hard at work as the
head researchers developing an
experimental device known as the lang
scranton stabilizer the lss was intended
to work as a reality anchor but it was
in its early stages and still unstable a
seismic event rocked the research site
damaging several lss units and creating
a wormhole that transported dr scranton
to the pocket dimension hereafter
referred to as
scp-3001
this little pocket of space this
impossible world just adjacent to ours
has some unusual properties it causes
matter within it to deteriorate as its
hume level approaches that of the
environment humes being the measurement
unit for reality stability robert
scranton was trapped there in the red
reality alive for a terrifyingly long
time five years 11 months and 21 days
before the logs he kept ended there he
struggled to hold on to himself he
grasped desperately at shreds of his
humanity his memories even as the world
around him slowly ate them away finally
only one thing remained anna his wife he
could just barely remember her name
remember that he wanted to get back to
her there was a brief moment of hope on
december 23 2005 when the lss control
panel reappeared in a testing lab at
site 120 dr ana lang arrived to monitor
the situation a mass of bloody organic
matter appeared alongside it and as anna
called out for her lost love something
clattered to the floor and broke her
heart her husband's wedding ring stained
with unidentified organic matter
smelling of black blood and spoiled meat
she collapsed under the weight of the
possibility that her husband was no
longer lost in a physical sense but in
another sense entirely that this mass of
flesh unrecognizable as human might be
the man she once loved tying his
favorite tie for him on date nights
dancing drunkenly to living on a prayer
collapsing on the couch together
breathless with laughter and the sheer
joy of one another that he could be both
here at last but gone forever dr anna
lang was taken to the medical bay and
treated for shock years passed after
ana's last encounter with her husband
she carried the ring with her in her
pocket every day for the first few after
five years she threaded a chain through
it wearing it around her neck under her
clothes after 10 more years she stopped
noticing it was even on anymore it had
become a part of her engraved on her
heart with the memories of the man she
had loved lost and grieved with nothing
to go home to at the end of the day no
one to share her time off with anna
began to pour herself deeper into her
work she would never remarry she knew
that robert had been the only man for
her now there was only her commitment to
the foundation and the research she did
there and the silent promise she made to
herself that she would never let
anything like the events of january 2nd
2000 happen again but will they with no
reason to go home honest nights at the
lab grew later and later her colleagues
often joke that she might as well sleep
there since that was the only thing she
went home to do the sadness behind her
eyes tended to cut their jokes short
soon after making them though anna liked
the late night work the lab was still
almost serene she could disappear into
the research the calculations let them
take over and quiet the noise in her
mind the lights were dimmed no one was
asking her inane questions or bustling
around while she tried to focus there
was nothing but her notes and textbooks
the light of her lone desk lamp glowing
softly in the dark and the work it was
one of these late nights buried in a
mountain of paperwork that anna began to
hear a strange sound she didn't notice
it at first absorbed as she was in a sea
of calculations but soon it began to
permeate the room breaking through her
focus a rustling sound a crackling of
sorts quietly murmuring into her ears
though she was vaguely aware of it the
way you might be aware of the wind
rustling through the trees outside your
bedroom window she didn't truly hear it
until she smelled something faint but
foul it was no matter how muted the
unmistakable scent of rot she stepped
down from her lab stool her joints
creaking with effort as she worked out
the stiffness in her muscles she
adjusted her glasses peering into the
shadows for the source of the sound but
saw nothing of note she took a step
forward into the dark then another and
then another behind her the desk lamp
flickered then cut out entirely she
stopped blinking in the sudden complete
darkness and sudden silence the noise
had stopped the only sound was her
breathing quickened with fear she pulled
the phone from her pocket and turned on
its flashlight using its weak beam to
light her way she turned back to her
desk looking for the issue that caused
the light to cut out perhaps a short in
the wire or a bulb that needed changing
before she could take a look at the lamp
however something else caught her eye
there was something slick and red on her
stack of papers dripping onto the clean
white surface and staining it with gore
a closer look revealed what it was and a
shiver ran down her spine a kidney fresh
and human she couldn't bring herself to
touch it but somehow knew that if she
did it would be warm her heart pounding
in her suddenly tightening chest as the
noise resumed behind her wet slapping
louder than before her feet moved on
their own accord as she walked toward
the sound holding the flashlight in
front of her in a shaking hand the black
wall of the lab illuminated by the light
was smeared with something dark and
strange slick like oil but with a rotten
smell a closer look revealed that the
wall itself was beginning to change
drooping limpy like wet cardboard she
froze watching helplessly as the wall
bubbled crumbling to pieces suddenly a
hand emerged from the wall gray skin
slick with black fluid its fingers
surprisingly strong gripped her arm she
tore it away scrambling back and saw
that pieces of her lab coat had come off
melting into the gray skin of the alien
hand as the arm reached for her again
she stumbled and dropped her phone on
the floor casting its light against the
wall and the figure worming its way out
there it was
an old man naked and grey with slimy
decaying skin coming off in pieces its
throat was shredded an open wound and it
grinned at her with stiff shriveled lips
stretched over blackened teeth its eyes
were the worst part even amidst the rest
of the walking corpse they were almost
like a man's they were correct in shape
and placement but they were wrong they
were empty clouded over and void of any
warmth or mercy as he stood there the
ground beneath him began to dissipate
melting into an oily puddle that
enveloped her phone and snuffed out its
light there was only one thing left for
anna to do and so she ran
she turned and made a break for the lab
doors lungs burning from the effort she
cried out for the guard on night duty
frank her voice was shrill and pleading
he appeared from around the corner gun
already drawn eyes wide and alert at the
panic he must have heard in her voice as
frank tried to calm her down and she
tried desperately to explain what she
had seen the old man forced his way
through the lab doors leaving a trail of
corrosive black slime in his wake frank
fired his gun hitting the old man in the
chest twice he collapsed sinking into
the floor as his excretion broke away
the tiles beneath him as anna and frank
debated what to do next a drip of black
mucus landed on frank's radio from above
another drop fell landing directly in
his eye he screamed in agony the mucus
dissolving his eyeball on contact next
the empty grin appeared through the
ceiling and the old man fell on top of
frank tearing out his throat with its
bare hands anna knew that she had to
escape but where could she go
she couldn't think couldn't plan she
just knew she had to run she ran until
her feet suddenly stopped obeying she
was stuck she was sinking into the
ground and then she was falling down
down into a moldy dusty hallway dark
except for a nauseating greenish gray
glow she had been pulled into some new
nightmarish world she ran through a
nearby door and found herself shockingly
in her old apartment how had she gotten
here how did the old man know this place
there was her bed her desk her closet
she flung open the closet door to find a
pile of rotten corpses that poured out
and slopped onto the floor she covered
her mouth to choke back a scream turned
and fled then she was back in the hall
this time she recognized it it was a
twisted warped version of sight 120. in
front of her there he was
the old man had found her again and now
she was in his territory he stared at
her with those hollow eyes and for the
first time
spoke
he growled she stopped in her tracks
frozen to the spot what he said next
turned her stomach and brought tears to
her eyes
he knew her name again he repeated
he reached out to her with a hand that
had a tan line where a wedding ring had
one spin the same ring burning against
her skin under her shirt he cupped her
cheek and she felt the skin sting in
blister he kissed her her teeth-melting
infusing tongue turning to mush that
dribbled down her throat and choked her
her last thought through the fear and
despair was the egg of love her husband
was not lost he was found and he had
found her too
now they would be together forever now
go check out
scp-106 the old man and scp-106 the old
man origin theories for more on the
terrifying story of this iconic anomaly